à l'époque de l'empire de couches il y
avait l'électricité les pyramides qu'on
voit là
au sommet il y a de l'or l'or c'est le
meilleur conducteur pour l'électricité
c'était des foutuses antennes les gens
les gens venaient l'électricité les gens
ils n'arrivent pas à comprendre ça les
Égyptiens la science qu'ils avaient ça
dépasse l'entendement et les historiens
le savent
alors merci prends café tôt merci mon
Président merci d'être là mon chéri
d'amour merci beaucoup président merci
Violaine
et heureuse
magnifique en tout cas merci d'être là
et Violaine attention elle rigole et
tout mais grande grande
parce que c'est pas parce qu'elle est
sympathique c'est pas une sommité vous
voyez ou pas il faut le dire merci
beaucoup Violaine d'être là juste Gilles
avant on va avoir d'autres extraits de
maître Gims juste qu'est-ce qu'il a
voulu dire en fait maître Gims
maintenant
à sa manière mais ça en débattra est-ce
qu'il a raison ou pas mais en tout cas
il a dit que les Égyptiens au moment de
construire les pyramides posséder un
savoir incroyable et notamment qu'ils
avaient découvert l'électricité ce qui a
un scoop parce que on pensait que ça
avait été découvert il y a un siècle
mais non lui il dit que il y avait
notamment l'or qui est un conducteur
électrique qui était au sommet des
pyramides et donc il est formel parmi
plein de révélation mais celle là il a
plus noté
et que et que revisiter l'histoire ça
pose problème moi j'en ai marre de ces
gens qui ouais il y a des mystères moi
je suis allé au pyramide pour découvrir
le mystère en découvre rien mais on voit
les pyramides pourquoi est-ce que il y
aurait pas un savoir secret des
Égyptiens au moment des pyramides
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ne détenait pas
l'électricité qu'est-ce qui va vous
permettre en tout cas de démentir les
propos de Gims moi je n'en sais rien et
je dis que peut-être Gims a raison alors
on va se tourner vers nos deux
spécialistes Frank apeto pour vous c'est
du délire ce qui a dit après
ça serait on fouille l'histoire de
l'Egypte démarre 3300 ans avant
Jésus-Christ les pyramides en tout cas
celle dont on parle elles sont aux
alentours de 2700 violette vous voyez la
connaissance
et après il y a toute l'histoire d'une
civilisation si les Égyptiens avaient
les U l'électricité de leur regarder ça
ce serait su je pense que ça aurait
arrangé les gens qui ont créé par la
suite la Vallée des Rois les tombeaux
qui travaillaient sans lumière au
flambeau ou pas réflexion enfin voilà on
aurait eu des traces de cette découverte
pharaonique si je puis dire tout au long
de l'histoire égyptienne or il y en a
aucune et c'était pas le sens des
pyramides du tout alors c'est l'avantage
si vous voulez c'est que on a quand même
des textes
et on a dans aucun texte effectivement
on te fait allusion à cette électricité
en plus pour reprendre quand même parce
que j'ai regardé un petit peu ce qu'il y
avait après j'ai écouté ce qu'il y avait
été dit les pyramides ont été
recouvertes de calcaire blanc vous savez
quand Cléopâtre
donc il n'y avait pas d'or l'or elle se
trouve sur les obéisses qu'on est
d'accord et encore c'est même pas de
l'or c'est ce qu'on appelle de
l'électrodrome donc c'est un mélange
d'or et d'argent et on appelle ça un
pyramidon d'où la confusion
vizir et la visière était super fort
du soleil pour communiquer avec le Diora
effectivement de d'électricité et bon on
a quand même beaucoup de représentations
dans les tombes et effectivement ça
aurait bien arrangé les peintres et les
sculpteurs qui travaillaient dans les
tentes d'avoir d'être éclairé davantage
parce que le principal problème c'était
celui-ci ils étaient éclairé si vous
voulez avec des bols et des mèches qui
étaient remplies d'huile bon mais pour
les yeux c'était pas l'idéal pour la
peau c'était pas l'idéal et il
travaillait dans des conditions très
précaires en fait oui pour la
respiration la chaleur ambiante
travailler dans des constitutions on
rappelle ce qu'a dit maître Gims
Saint-Gilles il a dit que il y avait de
l'or au sommet des pyramides et que cet
or servait de conducteurs électriques et
donc possiblement l'électricité était
née au moment des pyramides voilà alors
c'est tout le débat et moi je vais vous
poser une question parce que c'est vrai
que vous êtes des savants le problème
mais il y a plein de mystères dans les
pyramides on ne sait pas ce qui est à
l'intérieur on ne connaît pas les
pyramides tout à fait d'accord alors il
y a encore des mystères pourquoi est-ce
que vous n'y êtes formellement que parmi
ces mystères peut-être qu'il y avait
l'électricité que les Égyptiens
heureusement qu'il est là que les autres
merci alors c'est vrai Gilles moi j'ai
une passion absolue pour la civilisation
égyptienne faut savoir qu'à l'époque des
pyramides les Égyptiens ne connaissent
pas la roue non pas la roue ils ne
connaissent pas les chevaux ou prête
beaucoup de connaissances aux Égyptiens
qu'ils n'ont pas le cheval va arriver en
Égypte quasi
donc il y a 1200 ans entre l'époque des
pyramides et l'arrivée du cheval en
Égypte le chat
et donc la roue les Égyptiennes ne
connaissent pas la roue à cette époque
là donc l'électricité t'imagine on a
tout le temps qu'elles sont
oui dans la petite phrase qui a choqué
entre guillemets les gens c'est qu'il
l'a dit les salles les historiens le
savent comme si on nous le cachait et du
coup tout le monde le traite de
complotiste et moi j'en ai marre qu'on
trouve n'importe qui de révisionnistes
qui vont cacher la vérité le mec c'est
un artiste il donne une interview de 2
heures ça fait une polémique de fou sans
rigoler interview 2h qui est hyper
intéressante il parle de ces galères de
sa réussite c'est quand même un artiste
qui faut respecter et là tout le monde
le texte de conscience c'est n'importe
quoi de donner son avis et c'est pas
parce qu'on peut ne pas être d'accord
avec lui on peut croire en ce qui dit et
maître Gims c'est pas un prof d'histoire
c'est pas un média les gens encore droit
de parler bien sûr
parce que j'ai écouté ce qu'il disait et
son enthousiasme on va dire et c'est
justement cette enthousiasme qui est
intéressant je veux dire qui parle de
l'Égypte comme ça il aime l'Égypte
manifestement il aime la frite bien sûr
aussi incontestablement et il y a un
côté touchant il y a un côté formidable
donc en dehors bon il est pas obligé
d'être savant je veux dire tant pis et
puis on a pas besoin non plus de tomber
dessus comme ça alors regardez ce qu'il
dit je peux vous assurer que les
historiens ne lui en veulent pas du tout
alors dans la même interview Gims a
poursuivi voilà il a dit il va falloir
reprendre d'autres théories ce sont les
Africains qui auraient peuplé l'Europe
avant l'arrivée des eurasiens et il y
avait une réelle chevalerie noire
regardez
fric un peuplé l'Europe avant les
Européens on les appelait les afro Pen
ils ont été décimés par les vrais
européens entre guillemets qui venaient
d'Asie qu'on nous appelions
50000 ans avant les Européens la notion
de la chevalerie on l'avait déjà tu
retrouves aujourd'hui des tableaux qui
sont classés
cachés dans des catacombes c'est des
renois qui sont moins de chevaliers sur
Lancelot tout ça bien sûr ça existe déjà
bien sûr c'est juste qu'il faut
connaître notre histoire on veut nous
faire croire que notre histoire elle a
commencé sur la maigrir on apprendra
mais en sueur non
mais moi ce que je voudrais agir juste
sur sur sa dernière phrase il y a eu
dans l'histoire égyptienne des pharaons
noirs qui inquiété
en fait
non mais encore pas ça n'a pas démarré
au moment des galères et encore
effectivement il y a des pharaons noirs
effectivement il y a des Chevaliers
Noirs au Moyen-Âge des tableaux de
chevaliers noirs au Moyen-Âge encore une
fois ce qui pose problème c'est comme
quand il dit les historiens nous le
cachent là il dit les tableaux sont
cachés dans des catacombes les tableaux
de sont absolument pas cachés dans des
catacombes pas les tableaux on peut les
trouver dans tous les musées
dans la tête de Gims
il est plus avocat
il veut prouver en quelque sorte que
contrairement à ce qu'on dit l'Afrique
était un continent roi qui avait le
savoir avant l'Europe il veut retourner
l'histoire en disant c'est pas l'Europe
qui a dominé l'Afrique c'est l'Afrique
qui s'est créé et les Africains ont
peupler l'Europe puis on était
exterminés à un moment bon ça c'est un
peu plus contestable mais le fait de
dire que il s'est passé des choses
incroyables en Afrique avant que
l'Europe après ne règne sur le monde en
quelque sorte ça madame et c'est
vraiment intéressant je trouve ben moi
je trouve que c'est tout à fait
plausible mais enfin ça c'est bien déjà
il n'est pas si bon on pose le problème
on pose mal le problème il est pas
question de dire que les Européens ont
dominé avant les africains ou autres la
question n'est pas là la c'est une
question de culture de culture de
connaissance et il est évident que il y
avait pas des frontières dans cette
culture donc les histoires comment
expliquer ça l'histoire et la manière
dont elle était conçu et les concepts et
les dominants dominés etc étaient les
mêmes en Afrique et en Europe c'était
construit sur les mêmes schémas voilà
alors je sais pas si je suis clairement
donc c'est pas du tout on pose mal la
question et même à la limite Gims non
c'est ridicule de dire les les Africains
sont supérieurs aux européens ou voilà
la question se pose pas comme ça
il dit que les historiens le savent ils
disent tous les
jours
donc est-ce que ça c'est ne faire tutu
c'est ce que
il l'a dit
c'est une maladresse de sa femme si tu
sais une volonté de faire le buzz qui a
surtout c'est que c'est pas le premier
parce que c'est quelque chose qui n'est
pas voilà il y a eu carrément une chaîne
Youtube consacrée à ça c'est pas le
premier qui dit ça évidemment
est-ce que c'est vrai il y avait ça
avait été alimenté vous dites qu'il y a
des textes par un bas-relief ou avec
quelqu'un un Égyptien à quelque chose
qui ressemble à une ampoule et en fait
c'est le c'est le dieu armsong tous qui
est
vous connaissez
il y a énormément c'est une grosse
ampoule bon ça ressemble un peu à une
aubergine évidemment
qu'est-ce qu'il a ce Dieu c'est qui ce
dieu tu as tout fait tout ça
alors donc en fait c'est parti ce n'est
pas le premier
que tout le monde le sait alors écoutez
vous le savez avec l'Egypte il y a
toujours des mystères comme on a
construit les pyramides et autres et
tout ça non mais c'est très important
pourquoi il y a-t-il tous ces mystères
et pourquoi parle-t-on de l'Egypte
différemment que de la graisse de Rome
et autres ou effectivement
le pays il faut le dire mentretenir ces
mystères à tout intérêt à entretenir ces
mystères il vit du tourisme et les
touristes et les gens de l'étranger les
étrangers adorent les mystères égyptiens
et qui veulent pas vraiment rétablir la
vérité
ez que régulièrement tous les ans ou
tous les deux ans on lance un événement
une découverte de momie ou autre exemple
[Rires]
il a raison tu sais que la malédiction
en Toutankhamon a donné naissance au
film de momie qui a été à une
exploitation cinématographique à une
certaine époque
énorme parce que on a créé la
malédiction tout en canon donc en fait
c'est tout bête c'est tout simplement ce
sont des affaires comme commerciales
voilà et
je voulais vous dire quelque chose du
coup j'ai oublié mais c'est vrai que à
chaque fois que ce soit là la création
du grand musée qui va ouvrir qui n'en
finit plus d'ouvrir d'ailleurs
l'exposition Ramsès qui a lieu en ce
moment et qui vient d'ouvrir
comme il y avait eu l'exposition de
Toutankhamon également tout ça ce sont
des événements qui sont faits à la fois
pour rapporter de l'argent parce qu'on
en a besoin notamment pour la création
du grand musée au cœur et puis parce que
l'Egypte vit à 95% du tourisme voilà
donc voilà donc bon maître Gims il y a
pas de collant vouloir
les historiens le savent pas moi ça
bascule
pour moi ça ne me pose pas de problème
vraiment merci Violaine d'avoir été avec
nous